so automate chess you have 35 points to
spend on pieces
and then you set up your pieces and
however you want
and then you just sit back and relax
i'll probably
sit forward and commentate
um complete rules oh
complete rules
so we basically just choose our position
and then just watch the engine play
all right um let's just dive in
and we'll see what happens oh this name
is scary
so it's a blank board
i assume we have 30 seconds to make each
move
okay ah so the score goes down
too interesting
i'm probably just gonna like
stack as much as many pawns as possible
i'm not sure though
that's my strategy i should really have
a strategy
i don't want to get back mated
should i be a hipster let's be a hipster
double pawns but center pawns oh i can
make a pawn cube
oh i could make a pawn rectangle
right it said i have to i have
i have to place at least six pawns
it didn't say there's a limit
i can just fill the seventh and sixth
rank with pawns
let's go go for the porn cube
no it's like it's a pawn rectangle or
it's just a really stretched out cube
wait what do you call a
three-dimensional rectangle
alexa what's a three-dimensional rect oh
i
unplugged alexa because i tripped over
the cord no
alex is kind of dead at this point
do i have siri i have siri
what's a three-dimensional rectangle
here's what i found oh you're not as fun
as alexa
oh a prism or a prison
i don't know a box
okay opponent better not mess with this
immaculate cube of greatness i should
probably save
room for other things
maybe i'll just get knights i should do
math
to
[Music]
opponent fiance their bishop this
bishop's not so great against my
my pawn my pawn rectangle
ah so there's increment it looks like
nice
yeah the bishops can't wait i ran out of
ponds what
oh i only had eight pawns to be oh
oops there goes my pawns
okay so i have to start placing pieces
in the future oh hello to future wes
nation
everyone say hi in the the youtube
comments
okay the knights will maybe just chill
uh
i'm debating whether to have like one
rook
oh i'm running out of points
uh-oh ah i gave way the past pawn too
wait that's not good
i should have i should have expanded my
rectangle a bit further
i feel i feel like i'm messing this up
wait oh wow
oh i don't know what to do
okay so i'm gonna have rook is four
that's good so i can
place one more knight and then a rook
and i don't know how it's going to match
up against the imbalance
but at least i'll have some nice
symmetry
opponent has three dark sword bishops
that can't be a good strategy i don't
think
i'm gonna put my king on e8 and it's
just a massive
palace of greatness let's go
wait where's my king
what oh i have nine left
oh i can't do oh i i was reading white's
score not my score
let's play point nice my streamer is
back on oh
my eric oh no she is from italy my
escrom
thanks for the bits
and the cheers oh it was a cheer cheers
or cheers cheer oh it's my my turn again
or no
oh i can keep placing pieces right why
why used up all the points
okay uh i wanted symmetry
um okay let's just do this and then put
the king here
wow so i'm done doing any mental work
that's so nice now his points are gone
put king last
okay i figured it out man the engine
better not mess this up
look at this beauty it's like a triangle
illuminati oh they're playing really
fast too
okay uh what's going on
hey it's another illuminati keeping
symmetry
impressive no these nights are gonna be
so monstrous
and they dance around like horses kind
of
oh white has some pawn storm
man these bishops these bishops are no
match for my knights
ah that was a positional mistake there's
no reason to take that bishop
but the engine doesn't understand or
maybe it does
let's go let's go
yeah push those pawns the light controls
h8
so there's no rookie chase
and this is so fun it's just playing all
the engine moves
no there's no way white's surviving this
i have four knights oh but there's
wait two rooks and a bishop for three
nights and four pawns
ow why'd you playing a pawn
i found this last night i found the most
success with eight pawns and eight
bishops lol
i don't know i feel like knights are
stronger than
no it's gonna be a draw why no you can't
mate with
oh stockfish really doesn't understand
chess what is this
ah that's so disappointing black was
like easily winning that i thought
you can't allow all the pawns to go away
the engine just doesn't understand the
strategy though
that's really disappointing
it messed up such a good position
yeah just like walk the king in and then
leave leave everything defended
and then later play g4 it just doesn't
understand long-term thinking
at least i didn't lose
that was fun maybe i'll put that on
youtube
my first game of automate chess i tried
to use the strategy of the pawn
rectangle
combined with knights i guess that's the
problem with knight so if you wind up
with two extra nights against a lone
king you can't mate